M it's God
it's it's
God it's
God
guys I have a friend of mine who's on
the panel right here uh and he wanted to
share something with the
stream H how you doing
brother I'm doing well how are you can
you hear me fine I can hear you just
fine man it's been a while since I heard
you
[Laughter]
voice yeah I'm doing well brother um I
really thank first of all I thank you
for having me on thank you for coming
are you kidding me yeah it's been it's
been a crazy ride for me and uh I really
wanted to reach out to uh the brother
and sister
Muslims and tell them
about the truth about Jesus
and I the best way to do it is really
just my own Journey if that's okay by
you absolutely guys I want you guys I
can't you know say who this is
exactly um and you you'll see in his
testimony I want everyone to hear this
uh I'm not going to spoil it I'm gonna
let him tell it he only only from the
horse's mouth but you guys want to hear
this you guys want to hear this so
please his testimony his story blessed
me I've been in contact with him for a
long time now and uh man go ahead uh
brother brother Cyro I I guess I'll call
you cypher on here
cyer yeah go ahead man let let us let us
know let us know where you coming from
all right sounds good
um
so
I grew up as a as a
Muslim and I cannot really share much
information about my personal life but
what I will say is that I grew
up as a
Muslim and I
am an Arab my family is as Arab we are
originally
Syrian
and basically but we I lived most of my
life in the United States so but I did
but my community here is all they're all
Arabs and so I learned the language here
I've never been to the Middle East but
again my community is all Muslim we're
all Arab and I did not grew up very
religious as a as a child but as I grew
into my
20s I uh started exploring more about
Islam and the
Quran and uh little by little uh just a
small group of friends of mine started
decided to start getting into learning
about the faith about Islam
and then we became
religious um we kind of reached the
conclusion we're not Quran alone but
even though some Arabs would say we are
Quran
alone but uh we're
more I would say Quran oriented uh and
really this is a a a huge Trend in the
Arab world that a lot of Muslims are
starting to realize that a lot of the
hadiths are bogus
and so most a lot of Muslims including
my little group and I we we became more
Quran oriented in the sense that if a
Hadith agrees with the Quran then we
take it and if a Hadith does not agree
with the Quran we reject
it and so as we journeyed through this I
started uh looking more into why does
Allah want us to do our ritual
prayer for what
benefit why does it have to be in this
manner or in this way and little by
little I started to real I started to
raise a lot of questions about the
rituals of
Islam uh and I noticed that there's a
lot of problems because some people were
saying oh these are you know originally
Pagan they're spin-offs from Judaism and
all these things and the the biggest
thing is that
Muslims uh well I should say Arab
Muslims don't like Jews and yet when you
look at the ritual of the rituals of
Islam they're very similar to
Judaism so as I grew up and started
exploring the Quran I started to realize
there is something going on regarding
the things that are mentioned in the
Quran I started looking at uh videos by
David
wood uh Christian Prince Rob Christian
uh including yourself God logic don't
worry you're you're my
list uh and all these guys and one thing
that really struck me is the idea or the
notion that the Quran is not
preserved this is a very common theme
amongst Muslims is the idea of the
preservation of the Quran yep and to me
I said oh no way the this the Quran is
perfectly preserved it's the Bible that
was corrupt not the Quran MH but I went
out of my way to look into
this and I started looking into what is
called the
manuscript uh one of the oldest known
manuscripts of the Quran is the S
manuscript and specifically the palum
sests of the S manuscript and I noticed
that again Muslims brothers and sister
Muslims you are invited to actually look
into this the oldest known manuscripts
of the Quran are theat manuscripts which
date estimated late 7th
Century if you look at them they do
not coincide with the Standard Arabic
text that we have today they do not and
I'm talking about differences not only
in in in the the the vowels the do uh
the vowels that supposedly are are there
they're not but we're talking about
differences in wording switching around
words added words omitted words and so
forth Yep this this defies the whole
idea of preservation now of course
you're going to
have uh you're going to have whatever
scholar or some dude from speaker Corner
tell you oh yeah but it's a different
dialect and what not no no no no no no
no if you speak Arabic it's not a
dialect we're not talking about garage
versus garage we're not saying that okay
we're talking about entirely different
words folks yeah so I'm not going to BS
anybody I'm telling you if you speak or
read or understand Arabic you are
invited to to look in in it into it
yourself and just simply Witness
that in indeed the Quran is not
preserved in the sense of how we are
talking about preservation right and
then I got into well that so that was a
big red flag for me and then I got
into uh the the the stories the
historicity that is mentioned in the
Quran the biggest one for me was the
genealogy of Jesus in the
Quran
that I think I think it was David wood
that brought it up in one of his
videos um and he David W an apostate
Prophet uh they both talked about this
um you know when you go in the Quran and
you look at it and you read it plainly
like in Surah
three uh where you know you have Iman
right Iman or amam and then he G he his
wife gave birth to
medium and she is called sister of Haron
the sister of Aaron in Surah 19 so from
this You can conclude if you just read
the Quran you would think that Aaron is
the uncle of Jesus
yep Y and so and of course there is uh
you know there's some people that said
oh there's a Hadith that says oh it was
common back then to mirror the the
genealogies of uh the Israelites and
whatnot and I said oh hold on hold on
hold on we we can say that sure but
again if we read if we are reading the
context of the Quran it is obviously
speaking of the timing of
Imran the guy that is uh the father of
medam of the Old Testament who is also
the sister of Aaron and
Moses Y come on folks come on so so as
you could see there's a to me I tried to
like resolve this in my head it did not
work okay that that's the truth and so
the Quran for example conflates the
medium of uh the Old Testament versus
Mary the mother of Jesus two different
women thousand of thousand years apart
and the Quran seems to conflate the two
so to me again this was a huge red flag
yeah and so uh from this and I'm sorry
for going on on this tangent but bro
it's I've been waiting for you to do
this
so and so I mean and there's many many
examples of this problem in the Quran
this aside from trying to
resolve trying to do apologetics for the
Quran you know Muhammad was a good guy
uh he he he was not a warmonger he was
not uh a child molester well whatever it
may be okay we're not going to get into
that but that
a lot of the things that are mentioned
in the Quran are problematic yeah and so
to me I said okay I'm I'm not I don't
believe I I I feel like the Quran is not
what it
is
divine okay sure it we may we may say oh
that has some interesting or good
passages kind passages sure but overall
its claim to being Divine is not true
there are no scientific miracles in the
Quran uh uh uh there are they're simply
observations that humans did at that
time nothing crazy the story of the
people of the cave that was a
fable that was a fable made by some
Christian Bishop hundreds of years
before Muhammad and the Quran claims it
is divine
yeah so uh so this is my contention is
that you know there's a problem with the
Quran in this respect so what this justy
right there Cypher I just just
interesting interesting point that the
Quran gives a challenge bring something
like it bring a chapter like it right
right when it's literally taking stories
that exist from fables that existed
hundreds of years before taking so I
guess these things are I mean the
challenge was already met these things
are just like the Quran so much like
that you put it in there exactly exactly
so but go ahead man you spitting facts
right now go ahead so um like I said I
I've spent almost 10 years with some my
friends working on quranic
apologetics and the most important thing
is to be absolutely honest with
yourself you know and I it was I didn't
tell my friends I didn't tell them hey
guys I'm I'm starting to have doubts I I
kept it to myself because maybe I'm
wrong you know maybe I'm wrong so I
decided to buy a
Bible and and say why are you know
because I would watch uh I love this guy
uh Bob from Speakers Corner yes sir dude
this guy sir the real Bob logic yes sir
if I see him I will definitely give him
a hug uh you know cuz I I I I really I
the the passion that came out of this
man uh influenced me I go why would
someone like this guy for example uh who
believes in a trinity which is silly to
believe in you know three Gods okay and
the Quran made that mistake thinking
it's three
Gods uh why why would someone so
passionate believe in this thing and go
in the streets and you know risk his
life y y and
uh uh and do what he does why why would
he do that and so it made me very
interested to see Christians the way
they are in the streets preaching and I
go they believe in something so silly
and yet they're passionate about it I am
curious to see what these guys are all
about
amen that's what really made me you know
go to the Bible aside from the problems
with the Quran I go to the Bible and see
what is this
so I decided to skip all of the Old
Testament it's it's so dense I
mean
uh yeah yeah I I decided to open the New
Testament I was like well you know Islam
and Judaism you know kind of hand inand
I guess but Christianity okay let's go
so I opened
Matthew I open Matthew
brother
yeah
yeah open the gospel of Matthew saw the
words of our Lord and
savior the powerful words of our Lord
and and I'm I because you told me and I
love your story this is why I'm not
going to give any spoilers I'm gonna let
you say
everything but you experienced just by
opening the gospel and seeing the words
of Jesus and how he
lived oh give me a minute man I'm just
these tears oh hey hey it's all right
man Thugs Cry man you still you still
got street cred you still got it you
still got street cred
Cipher but ladies and gentlemen this is
why I wanted you guys to hear this man
because I i' i' I met him about a year a
year and some change ago right but about
a year ago some change Cipher
and I was
I I had to stay glued to him and his
journey and his walk you guys as he as
he goes on and tell it you guys will see
why but yes so you open the Book of
Matthew
Cipher so I opened the uh Book of
Matthew and
um H okay okay it's all out it's all out
it's all out more is Gonna
Come
so I open the Book of Matthew right I
I'm just uh you know I was like okay
this is the beginning of the New
Testament whatever and honestly I I read
through Matthew the first time kind of
like oh this is silly oh demonic POS
what are you talking about you know like
this you know that kind of like a
brushing it off Y and then I close the
Bible again uh I I I closed the Bible
and then I decided you know what I'm
going to give it another shot that was
like like a month after you know I just
Clos it just put it away I opened it
again and then I went through
Matthew and as I'm reading it's like
Jesus was speaking to
me everything all the questions I
had about the prayer about the fasting
about
adultery everything that Jesus was
saying he was like addressing my
questions that I had when Jesus said
when he talked about the prayer uh don't
he was talking to the Jews but he was
talking to me you know like because
Muslims are kind of you know we we're
almost like the Jews in that respect uh
uh Jesus told them when you pray don't
re repeat empty words like the pagans do
standing in street corners and whatnot
and when and you know where where I live
where I where I live it people do that
you know
uh the fasting when Jesus said when
you're fasting don't look gloomy in your
face but anoint your head with oil and
and all these things that Jesus was
talking about Jesus was addressing he
was hitting the the the the the the the
nail on the head yeah with that you know
and it just spoke to me and I in and
again I'm inviting my brothers and
sister Muslims open the Bible read what
Jesus says
it is powerful love your enemies all
these things that Jesus was talking
about was just I mean just so striking
for me yeah and then in my heart as I
was reading through
Matthew in my heart I said this sounds
so
amazing uh and and and
and it it just felt it felt right to me
yeah and then of course as with every
Muslim what about the Trinity what is
going on and
whatnot I look this is a a very normal
thing for especially a Muslim to
struggle with the concept of the Trinity
the the Quran gives the unfortunately
gives the Muslim the impression that
Christians worship three gods they do
not we do not worship three gods yeah
the Quran again this shows how the Quran
is ignorant in that respect yep it is
not from Allah it's not from God because
God quote unquote didn't even understand
what Christianity is all
about so yeah that's deep I mean we can
we can get into I mean maybe in another
in another video but like the the we can
get into the breakdowns you know we can
get into breakdowns of all these things
yeah for sure
but my intention here is to Simply share
my testimony so anyway I I go through
and I start asking questions I reached
out to you brother Avery I re I reached
out I uh I have a I have a friend an
Arab friend who's actually Christian uh
he's my childhood best friend
and he was so ex he was stoked when he
found out like dude you you bought the
Bible what yeah I can imagine yeah yeah
so he was really like he was helping me
out and answering questions and stuff
like
that um what I can say is
that I'm going to say this to my brother
brother Muslims and uh Muslim brothers
and sisters
Christianity is a lot more difficult
than Islam and I don't mean this as a
challenge or a one one upping but
because Jesus throughout the New
Testament is telling you your faith has
done this to you your faith has saved
you your faith your faith your faith
whereas in Islam it's all about works
works works when I was a Muslim praying
five times a day I felt like I'm all
set but no Jesus says look
inside he says if you think about a
woman in lust it's as if you already
committed adultery in your heart
yes whereas in Islam it says don't look
at women oh oh that's well I can try not
to look at women but in the Bible Jesus
tells you no no no no no if you're
looking at her in your mind you're
already committing that adultery it's a
lot it's a lot Jesus is more personal
more it's more inward okay
so so these are the things are kind of
like that came out to me in when I was
reading the uh New
Testament now as I was journeying
through I did not share this with
anybody except for my
wife and she was your your wife at this
time is still a Muslim right yes yes she
Muslim but what I did is that I bought
her I got her an Arabic
Bible and uh she started reading it and
she said I love the teachings of like
automatically like it's like her and I
kind of like sing s very quickly
together glory to God now
God but see I I I still did not declare
myself as a Christian per se right I I
just felt I felt like there was
something there's something amazing
that's going on right
now so uh a little bit of a background
about me um I've been
having uh sleep paralysis problems I
don't know if you know what sleep
paralysis is yeah y yep so for those
yeah for those who don't know what sleep
paralysis is it's basically you're
you're asleep and you partially wake up
you your mind wakes up like you feel
awake but you can't move you're
paralyzed and a lot of times in this
episode you
may uh go back to deep sleep or you
might just suffer for a a while in the
sleep paralysis until you snap out of
it um some people dismiss it as a
medical condition others do see it it's
a lot more it's a lot deeper than that
yeah anyway I've had I've had problems
with sleep paralysis since I was a
teenager but it wasn't until maybe 10
years ago whenever I get sleep
paralysis um this it's it's creepy okay
I'm going to get a creepy
here um 10 years ago as I was venturing
into Islam and getting into the Quran
and
whatnot uh whenever I get sleep
paralysis there was one time I would get
I had a sleep paralysis and I'm home
alone I'm sleeping and then I kind of
wake up but I'm stuck like I can't move
and I feel like I can't breathe and
whatnot next thing I know I hear
footsteps outside my door yep
and I my eyes are not open but I'm awake
if that makes sense right exactly what
you're talking about man yeah I'm aware
of my
surroundings the door
opens and I start freaking out I start
yelling ah like really
loud and next thing I know that thing
opens the door and runs towards my bed
and grabs my leg M and that's when I
like I went berserk yeah I went I went B
I mean I felt the the grabbing of my leg
Yeah um and then I I I eventually woke
up and you know there's nothing there
and whatnot um and and I can give you
many many examples of this story one one
of the freakiest ones that happened to
me
is I I'm at my parents house and it's a
full house everybody's asleep
uh I'm sleeping next thing I know it um
I I wake up in in
paralysis do you know the girl from The
Ring no the ring the movie The Ring no
all right I hope somebody on the chat
knows but let me look this up yeah dude
so it's this dead chick that comes out
of the whatever and from the television
and and yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah something very similar to that it's
a silhouette it's all black so I'm
asleep I'm asleep and I see a mirror in
front of me so I'm uh I'm sleeping on my
side I there's a mirror in front of me
and I can see behind me from the mirror
and I
see that thing behind
me and I start screaming so loud because
I can't move and I don't know what that
thing is and I'm screaming and screaming
and then she or it walks right over me
like I see her foot like right over like
she's standing over me because I was
sleeping on the floor at that time she
stands right over me literally like my
entire household woke up because I was
freaking out and then they they they
woke me up so anyway that's kind of a
background of what the things I was
going through before Christ H
BC
yeah now
um fast forward as I'm you know I'm
reading this the
Bible uh I've had a series of encounters
with a sleep
paralysis saved by
Jesus and so I don't want to mention
them all I'm gonna mention just a few
but and but they were they got
progressively more in touch with Jesus
so the first thing the first episode
that I H that I had I was
asleep and uh it was just a normal paral
paralysis and I'm screaming because I
can't move I can't
breathe yeah and next thing I see
there's a hand of a man that grabs my
shoulder and wakes me
up from the episode very mild and
actually it was my wife that woke me up
at the same time but but in the in the
dream or in the sleep it was a hand of a
man and I go and I the next and I
remember the morning I
said I said I told my wife I'm like you
know right before you woke me up there
was a a man's hand on my shoulder waken
me
up fast forward the next week okay fast
forward the next
week this one was pretty
intense so remember that the the dark
figure always visit me that dark figure
whenever I get the paralysis it it
always came to my bed or whatever so as
I was journeying with Jesus or to
Jesus um I I I I fall into sleep
paralysis again this was like like three
or four nights after that encounter with
that
hand uh I'm dreaming that I'm with with
uh I'm with my son we we are in a
strange home I go down the stairs into
the basement of the home and it's dark
next thing I know it I wake up in sleep
paralysis and I see that dark figure
zooming in right in front of me and I
start screaming ah and and and and the
lights were off ah and I'm screaming and
I could see that dark figure moving
about next thing I know it something
told me say in the name of
Jesus just some type of in inspiration
came to me in my dream to say in the
name of Jesus and that dark figure is
like moving about in the
room and the moment I said in the name
of Jesus my eyes again I'm in darkness
my eyes became like
flashlights
H and I was I I started laughing in the
middle of my nightmare because I was
utterly shocked I'm like this for 10
years I've been walking around in the
moment I said in the name of Jesus my
eyes became like flashlights in the
darkness
yeah and I started walking in and I
started walking in this dark basement
with my eyes lit and I saw the dark
figure and I don't know if Jesus was
telling me hey it's just a cartoon
because it was like a little drawing on
a on the wall and he was basically
telling me dude don't be afraid yeah of
this thing as long as you have my name
you will be okay that's right that's
right and then I woke up and I told my
wife this
story now I have one more one more thing
that I'm going to share with you the the
last thing that that happened to me with
the sleep
paralysis fast forward a few more days I
go through a sleep paralysis again just
a few days later dude they're all a few
days apart was under attack man yes yes
under attack for
sure wow this time I I'm in sleep
paralysis and I guess I fell asleep with
my arms kind like over my head and so
I've I felt I felt like I was
Shackled and I sensed a dark presence
coming to towards my
room okay I'm in paralysis I'm Shackled
that's what it felt like and the dark
presence is at my room and then I said
in the name of
[Music]
Jesus and then I saw
him right there with
you see guys there's power in the name
of Jesus
man you try him you taste him and you
see and he's
good he's real and he's
active even while we're Sinners even
while we reject him even when we don't
know
him man I thought I was finished crying
dang I told you more was coming I might
be a prophet I might be a prophet I
don't know but I told you when was
coming so I'm Shackled up I said in the
name of Jesus and that dark
figure was gone and then it
it was
Jesus that Jesus came to
me wow he uh and I I was shocked I was
like Jesus like I like I I couldn't
believe it
and uh he
uh he came up to my
bed and he I don't know like I I
couldn't make his face like I didn't but
I saw like a huge smile that's all like
really white
[Laughter]
teeth
um and he basically put his hand on my
shoulder and and he
said uh he said it's okay you're okay
you are fine don't
worry I I don't remember if it was he
gave me a
hug but uh
he but it was like he did
huh told you I'm a prophet man more is
coming it's gonna be tears all
throughout this stream
man I see y'all crying in the
chat and I see that you guys are
praising the Lord for our brother
here who who God visit
ited so uh he basically put his hand on
my shoulder and he said uh you're okay
don't
worry guys I I mean I'm not sharing with
you my personal life but I I have a lot
of you know baggage so to
speak and and then I told him I told him
get me out of these
shackles and then he put his hand on my
shoulder again smiling
he's like you need to go through
this you need to go through this but he
said it like he said it
like
uh not like oh you need to go through
this you know like no no he said it
gently in the sense that like you have
me but you need to take up your cross as
he
said and then I said what like I was
like no no get me out of here get me out
here he's like you need to go through
this
Habibi you know and then and then he and
then he went around my bed like in front
of me and then he smiled again and
pointed at me he's like you'll be just
fine but you need to go through this and
then he raised up his arms like in the
shape of the Cross and then he vanished
and then there was the cross like on the
wall H and then I woke
up
wow oh my gosh I got this off my chest
because I've been wanting to tell you
this story forever yeah now now this
guys this he kept from me he didn't tell
me he didn't go deep and tell me this
part and I feel Bamboozled I
feel I feel cheated but whatever I guess
I find it out with the rest of you I
guess I'm not that special incredible um
yeah and then I never like not not I
never but
um uh this is not to say that I don't
get sleep paralysis but I will say this
I get sleep paralyses still but whenever
that dark figure is around I just say in
the name of Jesus and it's
gone gone I used to recite Quran
I used
to all this stuff and nothing would
happen
wow but the moment I said yesu
Jesus
it's that's it it's it's gone how can
that be you know that's that's the thing
yeah and
so again this is I'm reaching out mostly
to my brother and sister Muslims
that there is truth
here Jesus is the
truth once you understand the falsity
the falsities of the Quran and again
this is not try to like again uh compete
or have something you know whatever no
I'm just simply sharing
my observations my testimony about
what's hap what's happened to me
mhm and
so you know that this happened just
recently in February of uh of last year
23 okay this happened to me in 2023 of
February just recently my my wife my
wife we had a new
child um she's about two months
old um
and uh basically my wife was kind of
late in her due date and she was
freaking out about like getting to need
induced labor and whatnot and so I
freaked out a little bit I got worried
every night after her due date I was
praying and asking Jesus
to you know let the baby come healthy
and everything and lo and behold I had a
sleep paralysis episode
uh I had a sleep paralysis episode
during that
time and I remember I saw the dark
figure just outside my door I said in
the name of Jesus that dark figure was
gone next thing I know it I see Jesus
right above me standing above me with
his hand on my
forehead
smiling and then he disappeared he
didn't say anything it was just like two
seconds he was there he disappeared and
next thing I know it I felt this sense
of awe and love inside of me yeah that
same morning my wife went into
labor wow yes so I mean guys it's come
on man it's ridiculous I mean ridiculous
in a good way yeah right right
wow wow
so uh
so these These are the encounters that I
had with Jesus and what what's amazing
is that I'm I'm listening to stories of
other
Muslims whom who encounter Jesus in
their dreams and I say this is such a
consistent
thing how could it be all a lie how
could the thing that we understand about
Isa which is not his
name be true but yet you see things you
hear things about Muslims encountering
Jesus in their dreams and I am one of
them
wow
yeah so uh yeah I mean I mean in
February when that happened that
ultimate Encounter With
Jesus uh I immediately went on my knees
and I gave my life to Jesus amen glory
to God glory to God
so uh
yes that's uh that's pretty much uh my
story and I wanted my brother and sister
Muslims to you know at least I know I
know it's hard I know it's hard I my
family doesn't even know I'm mus I'm
Christian they're all still Muslim yeah
and uh it's not it's not easy to share I
mean especially I mean if your family is
super super islamically religious you
can risk your
life I mean
so but the truth is
truth and that's what I'm after always
yeah and I think that's what everybody
should be
after you know don't worry about you
know what your family's going to think
or whatever
just go with Jesus open the Bible I
highly recommend I've learned so many
things as a former Muslim from the Bible
the Old Testament ask any Muslim ask any
Muslim what does ibraim mean the Bible
tells you what ibraim means why is he
called the the Quran for example doesn't
tell you that is and Y are the same
people I never knew that right I never
knew that so I mean I've learned so many
things
they're the same they're the same person
and the the Bible tells you why he was
his name was changed to is right right
you
know so I mean there's so there are so
many things to learn
from from the Bible and especially
especially the love the peace and the
glory that's in
Jesus Muslims are you struggling with
the idea of Jesus being god well he says
if you pray in my name period that in
the Arab culture is a blasphemy yes you
don't pray in the name of anyone except
for Allah you don't
say but no Jesus is
saying say in the name of Jesus so that
alone tells us Jesus Is God yep
100% so I mean I can get into like so
many different things with the Quran and
and the Bible and the comparisons and
whatnot but really I I I just wanted to
share with and thank you so much again
brother Avery thank you brother I really
wanted to reach out to these guys and
share with them my testimony because I
feel like dude I need to I need to reach
out I need to reach out to other Muslims
but without you know making sure that
there's some safety aspect safety aspect
in this you know I have been begging
this man for a year to come on the
stream and help
me help
me been begging this man uh but in God's
timing you know in God's timing when he
raises you up and uh you know you just
be obedient to When God says go you go
that's when you go not when I say not
when you say it's When God Says
and that's when God's timing is it's
perfect timing like I uh you know not I
just just momentarily I wanted to start
my YouTube channel a year before I
actually started it and I wasn't ready I
was not ready to start YouTube channel
uh I wasn't settled I wasn't um like
with when it come to the to my camera
and my mic situations I I just wasn't
ready you know I wasn't ready but when
God the very next the next year when God
when I was on God's timing and he said
go out do this and do this and I just
went out and did
it everything just amazing you know well
bro I mean when I reached out to you you
were I don't know 3,000 on your channel
that's it
yeah yeah yeah look look at God now man
Mah M sorry m yes
sure that's okay even in the Arabic
Bible Jesus is called Allah isn't he
yeah it's it's still habitual for me um
you know as a forign Muslim you know we
say masallah which is still fine you
know because the intent is there um but
you know I'm reaching out now to a local
Arabic
church um and I'm I'm I I'm better in
English than in Arabic even though I do
speak Arabic fluently I'm not used to
the Arabic Bible but you know it's
amazing this Arabic church the uh the
pastor there he was so excited to know
that um you know we're former Muslims
and he's like well we're gonna develop a
program where we're going to reach out
to the Muslims in the area and talk to
them about yesu yeah and I said yeah
that's amazing yeah you know and I and I
really look forward to that and I'm
honestly happy for you brother uh your
channel has has yeah yeah your your
channel I mean has grown so much and uh
you know you're doing such a wonderful
job I love you man I love you too
brother I love you too thank you so much
for blessing this stream uh I'm
literally I'm gonna make this its own
video because this right here does not
belong with what happened prior this is
its own special thing you know yeah yeah
uh
the thing yeah and then I'm sorry just
to to randomly text you like hey you
know I I found time me I what did I what
dude what did I tell you tell everyone
what I told you what did I tell you
about coming on and what do what do you
remember me telling you anytime any
freaking time man I don't care what I'm
doing if I'm not if I'm home and I'm
streaming you text me say hey man I'm
ready I'm stopping what's going on you
saw what I I stopped the conversation
with you saw that right I said I'm
moving on I'm moving on I'm moving on
because this right here I've been
waiting for you to do this praying for
you to do this and praying that God
gives you the courage and the strength
to be a weapon for the kingdom to be a
laborer and so in God's timing and in
God's Pace I waited patiently and I will
continue to wait to see what else God
does with you but I am here this
platform is also your platform whenever
you're ready you want to break down some
stuff let's do it you want to get on a
stream and make a quick little five
minute video or whatever breaking down
something that you think demon is
important or interesting let's do it you
know the Arabic you can break it down
you taught me stuff let's do it whenever
God says am that's my mindset you hear
me thank you thank you God bless you yes
all right all right well um I'm gonna
head out
um but yeah let's do this again um and
uh yeah we'll plan it out and I pray
that uh the brothers and sisters who
watch this at least it will touch some
some of the the Muslim brothers and
sisters um so yeah absolutely thank you
so much for sharing this man may God
bless you your family your
newborn uh and every everyone around you
everything you touch I pray that God's
hand is on you that he continues to
strengthen you continues to bless you
continues to empower you and man you are
you've brought glory to the name of
Christ you have brought glory to God by
speaking your testimony and the Bible
says that faith comes by hearing the
word of God faith comes by hearing
absolutely absolutely people's faith
will be built up by your testimony we
don't know who or where but man the more
we share this and the more we do this
people's faith will be activated because
of the spoken word absolutely amen amen
all right brother all right head out God
bless you yes sir God bless you guys
Salam
Salam oh my
godic
a